hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to welcome to the game now
much like the park I didn't get to this
when I first got to the game I am late
to the party here but I am gonna play it
fully and firmly right now sorry for
bumping the goddamn mic there so I dunno
the basic premise of the game though you
are trying to hack into a Red Room which
is a room on the Deep Web that is
supposedly a webcam set up to watch a
live murder of some sort it's a very
dark subject and very scary to think
about a lot but there is a mic option in
this game now I'm not a hundred percent
sure about this but if there is a mic
option in the game I imagine that it
works kind of like the one in lurking
where if you talk into the microphone
things will kill you so hopefully I'm
not gonna do that but I'm gonna play a
new game here and I'm gonna be I didn't
start it I didn't start another game who
is hacking my computer playing game Red
Room a hidden service on the Deep Web to
see a participate do you see and
participate in interactive torture and
murder I don't know why we're trying to
go for this but let's have a fun time on
this weekend I got the house to myself
so I might as well murder someone no
one's watching this it's kind of
revealing some deep dark secrets about
my soul use computer oh hello hi Adam
are you doing alright if I if this
tutorial is boring and you guys don't
need to know about it which you may
already know how to do it but I'm gonna
yes yeah are you sure you want to do
this
no the Deep Web it's full [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure there are some things
you can't unsee uh-huh
oh alright well don't say they don't
want you okay Deep Web is like a giant
maze uh-huh
there is no search engine right you have
to do some exploring to find what you
are looking for okay we do any that we
you are looking for our eight hitting
keys in the Deep Web Oh how'd all size
happen but some do you have to explore
each page click the links and see what
you discover huh
looks like this okay each key contains
an order number associated with them
this is important what you have found
all eight keys you have to type out the
complete key in order this will provide
you with the red rooms URL this is where
the notes system comes handy you can
keep track of all the keys you have
found when you explore the Deep Web
you're exposed to hackers these hackers
will attempt to hack you but don't worry
I want to have it installed some tools
to prevent this from happening there are
two kinds of attacks that happen to you
while you browse the Deep Web uh-huh the
first one being a denial of service
attack not so bad as a das attack
although the hacker attempts to Doss you
you will be prompted with the das
blocker tool to try and block the attack
oh you simply just have to click the
action no it's in the puzzle and
redirect the traffic to the exit node
this prevents the packets from flooding
your system you have to activate all of
them though if you don't you will get
hacked Oh
protip you can hold the middle mouse
button to speed up the process it's
gonna go ahead and launch a das attack
on you so you can test this out for
yourself
thanks man oh no I'm not ready I don't
want this oh boy life is gonna be a fun
funny game alright so what am i huh I
blocked the hackers I'm the latest
hacker in the room yeah
hackers will try to corrupt your kernel
and prevent you from using your system
having Colonel Sanders been through
enough how many people have made that
joke already I don't know thanks for
putting in at least two you simply just
have to type what you see on the screen
okay alright I'm a great typer typist
stack do it bring it on yourself
I hope it's extra crispy because I know
that I can handle it
often is this gonna happen okay version
one point lead okay what Oh
uh uh whee-hee I'm trying it wait why is
it what no that's that's not at all what
I did include iostream yeah hashtag
include studio H BAM what that was
exactly right don't tell me that I'm
wrong because you're wrong and stupid
and ugly and also I'm handsome and and
amazing yeah go Bakri maybe yo eat this
is just a number legend so huh sure if
it's true or not
urban legend about a the FIVB web did
the Deep Web there is kidnappers that
will try to locate and kidnap you just
an urban legend right yeah okay weird
information just to throw out there for
this if you think someone is tracking
you just turn all the lights off and be
quiet
don't say a word when you think the
coast is clear
turn the lights back on hmm are they
here no okay all right so apparently
there be kidnappers sorry I'm just I'm a
male model I'm trying to fuss with my
hair all right whatever the lights off
well once you zoom out the computer mode
by hitting the right click button hit
the 8s D keys to look around and click
on the light switch behind you well
that's it good luck oh no wait oh god no
oh god no I had no idea this was
actually gonna be a component of this
ooh I'm not about this because I scream
a lot I'm very loud anyone would be able
to know okay all right then let's go on
the internet why is this worth it
why am i doing this is that not working
okay homepage ah that's a lovely
homepage very happy but oh these oh
these all look great nude youtubers
boy howdy oh boy click click dead that
sounds good to me don't know what this
is all about
oh not available that's probably for the
best
unless I'm click click already dead so
how would I know if there's I mean these
aren't gonna work these aren't gonna
work cannabis world I want to go to
cannabis world chosen whoa I mean heck
all right good
Oh to be kidnapped before him Am I am i
oh it's just a Doss I can do this ok uh
that's gonna go oh jeez that's not right
Oh jeezum 'he's okay yeah yeah yeah take
that honker you can't mess with me leat
okay what is this you have been chosen
you have always been awake seeking and
you shall find nothing will be achieved
without time and tenacity question and
it shall be earned look less and learn
brothers and sisters continue air charge
reject hatred and embrace love well
that's awfully nice that the Illuminati
oh is that a number that I need to know
about maybe I don't know what these
symbols mean whoo boy whoo that's a lot
of weirdos okay I don't know what any of
this means but there's some numbers here
is that important I don't know I have no
idea okay
sorry hackers that was all for nothing
cotton road ooh
pills 8-ball crack perfectly exactly
what I need
Oh Roger Dodger in the speed pill so
what the heck is this
oh come on but I was so close to buying
crack man do I just got to go through
all these like individually and
hopefully some of them are available can
I get some stimulants maybe some opioids
oh this ain't going well psychedelics
precursors don't know what that even
means what the heck is a precursor so
I'm thinking that this might be hopeless
unless looks like kind of like
individually go through each of these
can I get some sweet sweet LSD no okay
all right bye everybody
sorry apparently I can't buy anything on
here but
I'll be on my own be on my way and on my
own your oh [ __ ] oh yeah no no my house
okay and Bing bong Bing bong I'm a
winner I'm a winner hack bak bak bak
grandma's fantasy I don't know if I want
to go to Grandma's fantasy God none of
these sites work how am I supposed to be
able to know what time they go on father
Donald no that's a negative
nope grandma's fantasy No thank goodness
nope hot burners oh oh yeah they got
bodies on him
hot burners is my only one snapshot
before I do a hit Russian assassin okay
bye now
nope ah man it's hard to get a code
apparently I thought it was this this is
not what I was expecting by the way when
I thought of this gamer when I I heard
about this game I did I did not know I
mean I knew it was about trolling the
Deep Web and trying to get to a Red Room
but man I didn't know it was gonna be
literally trolling the Deep Web and
trying to get to a Red Room
[Music]
laid out its no proving lay down okay I
don't know what that sound means but
apparently it doesn't mean I'm about to
be kidnapped which is good okay I don't
know what that sound means but it
probably something important
let's go to nude youtubers am I on here
oh man
got too damn shame how about passports
are us I don't want to talk kiss I might
get hacked ma puts a lot of stress
hey buddy dolls I don't know what that
means nothing's working
nothing's working pirate hackers why
would I go okay thought I thought I
heard something Oh scream [ __ ] nope
nothing there
shadow web portal ooh you've reached the
hidden gateway in the shadow web to get
to the browser bundle required ask the
shadow web sent 200 dollars below was a
payment is made will content you with
the download link to access instructions
shadow web URLs host content too dark
for the deep webs
okay so 9 9 f 9 CF BB SH web ah come on
I thought I had something there but
apparently not okay now that one doesn't
even work anymore
I can't go back enough dang it now it's
just down I gotta go back to the
homepage the bunker oh okay well it's
day 2 when did I get to day two when did
i sleep what happened okay there's
nothing at the bunker there's nothing
here
there's nothing for me can't find
anything the butcher what am I looking
for
Oh butchering the butchering the human
carcass for human consumption by Bob
arson that's a great name human being
also referred through throughout
culinary history has long Pig
or hairless goat ooh oh I don't want to
know anything I don't know any of these
wabbit I'm here
why me why why does that happen
what's with that noise is that I don't
know that means oh oh there oh for oh
wait okay wait oh okay
enter okay so that's what it means it
popped up somewhere else on the screen
when I hit that button okay so if I go
back Oh what was it Euro firearm that
happened when I was little firearms
before so I think oh it was a colonel I
don't know how to do the oh boy oh boy
Oh what no that's not right no oh I
can't type correctly I'm in stress oh
boy
okay and then yeah on in stage William
oh no it's not available now damn it I
don't know which one of these were
unavailable before man this is gonna
take forever this is what I have to do I
already been to cannabis world that
means on cannabis world there definitely
was probably something there that I was
gonna be able to do something
[Music]
I thought I heard something in fact I'm
pretty sure I heard something so I
clicked on that thing which means that
it's probably on this page somewhere
a clickable
[Music]
okay
I can't find any other clickable on this
page but that did click something just
don't know what else it did okay this is
last button on I was about this is
actually okay so it's Colonel I got to
do some topping here
that's too many types oh boy
oh god I've messed it up already no no
oh Jesus oh boy uh can't think can't
talk and type at the same time guys oh
boy Oh
get new spoof I did good man okay I'm a
hacker shields but that did nothing why
did I get hacked if that wasn't gonna be
a button that was gonna be doing
anything damn it oh man if I only got in
that first code I didn't know what a man
I gotta get all the yelling out right
now barrage tool a doll maker
oh well that was the website oh I create
women slave toys because you're
wondering what I mean oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh there's a creepy website
alright so that wasn't productive at all
god I want to get one more I want to get
one more the butchering didn't have
anything did it oh no way that's where I
already got one the butchers where I got
one
hello
goddammit immediately back I'm busy
oh boy okay
so there we go oh man that was so
stressful you guys definitely heard that
right that was a thing that wasn't just
nothing that was actually a thing not
good
okay okay so that was a bust
I didn't do anything for me oh man this
is too stressful for me not fun
don't do that okay yeah all right
oh oh oh these these are lovely samples
hmm okay okay this doesn't seem to have
anything also the music might have
covered up someone sneaking up behind me
but I don't know about that
whoo brothers and sisters of God I call
it and I saw a great white throne and
him look was opened which is the book of
life and the dead were here by was
written in the books oh you got it okay
got another one yeah okay so that one
was only available at a certain time of
night
which is good right I got another one
that's good okay and lube today for I've
taken four days to be able to do this
when is nude youtubers gonna be open I
don't know how am I supposed to know
when these things are supposed to be
open oh no it's hot burn
[Music]
bingo bango I got three of them I got
three all right baby
it might have been my imagination
hi
is he gone oh I'm dead I'm dead hi [ __ ]
you who's not gone god dammit or the
[ __ ] steps top oh man oh man the
footsteps stopped I can't continue god
dammit Oh sucks I was doing so good oh I
thought he was gone man
having the mic that's so hard okay so
now I know what to do now when I play
this game again I'm gonna go through it
with a fine-tooth comb and like
meticulously write down notes for
absolutely everything that I've gone
through so that I know where to go where
I've been what has something
what doesn't have something so I'll
figure it out but man Oh stressful super
stressful to have the mic there I just
don't know when I can talk and when I
cannot doc hey the way that's all for
now thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye